open windows okay what's up guys welcome
back to the couch Dave joined by Lucy
today she's gonna basically hold my hand
while I play a scary game gonna be
difficult with two hands on the
controller told me to stay close to be
at my side because I'm the worst I am
the worst at scary games I was telling
you before I nearly can finish Bioshock
when that first came out Metal Gear
Solid 2 I couldn't finish because when
it gets to the ending and the game
starts talking at you I was like now put
it down for like five years
didn't come back to you precious little
flower so now we're playing the outlast
2 demo you've played out last one right
yeah okay so you've got to guide me and
make sure I don't get too spoopy you'll
be fun then it's a game it can't hurt
you you know this you are Blake
Langerman her cameraman working with
your wife Flynn that's my mom's name
listen I'm not calling you dad haha the
two of you investigating journalists
willing to take risks and dig deep to
undercover the stories no one else will
dare touch you are following the trail
of clues I started the seemingly
impossible murder of a pregnant woman
known only
the investigation is legend miles into
the Arizona desert to a darkness so deep
but no one who shed light and a
corruption so profound
and a chess game of okay all right I'm
ready
we're not get though playing a hurry
good ok ones are you barefoot pregnant
stretch of highway Baron hAER'S highway
so if it's over it's one Arizona Highway
it's evil it's upside down as well all
upside-down things really like walk
that's vampires said obscenity with that
thing doesn't look fun
that's a cross upside down that's devil
across one way across empowers owner
over losing expensive pick up your specs
there you go no no you recognising it by
just the grunts I played a lot of choice
that's never these like laughs again
oh yeah this is beginning there's the
camera thing but luckily for you it's
trouble I can light loads and you've got
a monitor battery I don't feel lucky in
any part of this oh I'm like I'm
invested in this game now gotta make
sure I'm safe oh Allah you can open the
door on her open till oppress the whole
deck so jammed already don't place
look that [ __ ]
did you ever know there was footsteps of
my left and on my left process only
known as footsteps I played enough Oh
God
buck is time are you mother
oh no I got a body batteries in look in
look at him
what's he been stabbed with spoon no
spoons in his bone I wasn't his hand a
plunger oh this is gonna be like the
longest 50 minutes my life oh I'm glad I
was in the Oh Oh who's I told you those
forceps Resident Evil 4 Jesus yeah but I
can't trace because ever actually
already sweet rice to live none of the
Hat is back
height
Morrow oh yeah Pete
ooh can I be seeing our Pekin think you
can
I already feel extremely uncomfortable
not having a great time yeah the camera
cameras doing 1080p though yeah no
wonder the batteries God does the quick
oh look we're going
Don't Tell City gyro base why is he
knocking if only maybe if I'd put on his
clothes I can disguise myself as one of
them right trying to close the door cuz
probably someone's gonna come you should
like close the door
I love that he's actually got like you
can monitor the audio the game of the
what you doing at the camera can you pee
good night thank you
weave around Oh freak yourself out is
anything else in this knob leaving
heythis what move backward alright yeah
yeah that's good that's good door
physics top door physics oh no isn't it
you see my pork I'm getting really
excited for the camera nightmares ooh
kids stuff spooky kids I don't but I
like speaking uh open windows okay
I get you just me I think it was your
right you can hide under the beds oh
there's another door Oh was it the
battery or something good good
I keep hearing things bothering me
forgot nor to stop her you said grace I
can see where the curtain why Chuck into
himself
I'm a Fiat Oh
oh good a the human size hole I'm not
being funny but like if this had
happened to your mum I was the only one
right looking for it I'd have been gone
and scrambled back of that hill oh yeah
great this looks homely oh cool let's
just descend into this hole I've been
playing like a battlefield so I saw that
glitter looks like like a dollar
baby Oh was that dead bodies a little
kids it's no no son I'm not turn my
camera off you try and try and keep your
battery oh cool I have all the kids toys
rocking-horse is one of those spooky no
dolls now as soon as I dug down the well
and look up there's gonna be something
that guarantee you smoke it's left 4
dead 3 I'm certain there's gonna be
something right there why else would it
tell me to look behind
teach me how to love again after this
from my experience it's your shine this
is this is the first time played at the
gym it's very gaming in years I don't
think the last collar game was up a
resident evil that's right it's like Oh
Sookie classroom this is all of it
creepy Colts Jonestown
kool-aid is it scary
yeah oh that's that's why I don't notice
a guy convinced like about a thousand
people to kill themselves I thought I
liked that thing I thought you'd might
like it was like a scene at like school
I went to Catholic school that's no way
to success
what about the door behind no now we
push forwards got down oh yeah laughing
laughing me laugh at my pain [ __ ] I
know you're suffering see the portrait
music box again it's quite a creepy
thing
it's how clean nails though yeah Center
I stopped oh yeah
what are you using a camera don't need
it it's like oh yeah
it's life oh hi
from what whatever that shadowy thing I
did touch it I'm out I'm leaving goodbye
[ __ ] you sure about that
I think you have to fight yeah
jams what's the time 20 5 / 6 play new
[ __ ] games but why is my vision doing
a weird because is it doing the amnesia
thing if it going mad this is my idea
myself
I usually hurry yes would you want to
play
I still gets guys you do it I'm out
Preston there you go
right where will we go in straight to
hell Oh light
my heart is racing
okay No never fails like that door
really fast I know so many people that
love movies and video games my
girlfriend love scary movies Oh scary
video games just like you replace them
together just to now not like hang on so
here's his place the door is Lisa its
Jessica the pregnant girl Oh why'd you
look at it why do you look at it I can't
a spooky thing happen let's look at it
no he's going so well the times I go
Welsh when I'm drunk - they're scared
those are like oh please
music scared of it well it doesn't seem
genuine out there because of my camera
audio sup picking anything up hey when
your heart being in the chest lie again
of the ceiling oh my days some sort of
art of the corn poor lazy scary things
wrong evolved that all of that I can't
you can just keep going I'm exhausted
suck it up
they cheese it here go for cheese in it
I should go to the light that's what the
percentage is my glasses again we feel
very uncomfortable
I was scared of him more or iess space
of about 30 minutes
well are you okay that was the outlast
demo if you enjoyed make sure hit that
like button subscribe to GameSpot and
happy Halloween relief I'm just gonna go
for a sit back